hey guys Ryan right Dan Seibert we're
checking out the trailer today if you're
called duty black ops 3 the N Bertie's
I'm a little late on this video I put up
the reveal trailer just yesterday so
here's the ember tease I and I
apparently missed this one so let's
check it out
today we celebrate the first draft of
the human Book of Life
it's been called the age of wearable
tech no making things happen when we
merge technology with our but we will
set the technological foundation for an
enhanced human experience and we will
end disability in our pursuit of
progress if we undermine the borrows
that defined us what good is on the 11
o'clock respect or declare
discrimination against modified persons
unconstitutional historic dance points
as the IBA becomes the first link to a
lot modified athletes to compete
victory scientists announced they
created these bursts a networked brain
to brain connection you know literally
share your thoughts with someone else
biotech markets skyrockets as DNA
upgrades and all the replacements become
the new luxury look at me and you see
only what you want to see what I see
everything
a 95 regular plate
you think the retinal chips that you buy
of the mall or high-tech our military is
lightyears ahead of that the things that
we use to eat you ourselves they are
using to literally turn humans into
weapons but no show that the United
States sponsors some sort of super
soldier program is not just untrue it's
patently absurd text question Mr Norrell
control voluntary limitless this is
happening the only question that remains
how far we allowed to go damn it I
really wish I caught that trailer first
that was I what's wrong you're at good I
like it a lot
that looks awesome I was honestly just
sitting here waiting for it they're like
we couldn't control the drones we built
it or they're gonna attack us I'm like
oh they did future war thing again but
no there's a really clever trailer to
start off like years ago and then have
it iam present and then go to the future
and it was all really interesting
because the way they were having it all
build up to the future and how bad it
gets with the turmoil the rebellion it's
not about like artificial intelligence
rebelling it's more about like how they
said it like scientists are playing God
it's becoming more of a threat the
technology it's not like they built a
robot and the robots gonna kill people
it's like yeah the technology they're
building in secret is really threatening
and like they're making super soldiers
I've seen movies that create super
soldiers before zombies yeah I mean even
in the Incredible Hulk then you like the
goal is create a super soldier yes true
in Captain America TV stuff in America
that is the plot yeah and so to see this
though in like kind of a apocalyptic
haunting fashion was interesting like
there's no gameplay in it but the world
that they're teasing you know I know a
lot of people are upset that Call of
Duty is now like so futuristic then it's
like I've seen that it's upsetting a lot
of people like [ __ ] man but it's
like where else can you really go with
it now I'm like no not when you pump out
you know like a billion every single
year yeah what are you gonna do I mean I
honestly can't wait for smurf warfare
it's gonna be my favorite installation
in the ecology
franchise spurts Worf Oh who's the
villain ain't callin in this it sounds
like the soldiers you play as are the
bad guys because there are the weapons
who says you can be playing as a soldier
plays a little
kid yeah who walks a dog around I think
it's equipped with a knife right the dog
they called them knife dog boy I like
the world the gameplay trave the reveal
trailer I saw I liked it too I feel kind
of stupid off of some things that set up
the reveal trailer because this one
answers a lot of it for me what is it
like that would be a great movie trailer
for something oh yeah and I like how
they got like actors to come on board
whatever put this together it was really
smart because that was like I dig it I I
feel like this is one of those cool
haunting futuristic thrillers and why
wouldn't I want to play in that rating
time people I am definitely going to
play call of duty black ops 3 I'll
Gamefly it
yeah whatever damn your new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
dan has a gaming channel check that out
do you follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter product placement is so cool
let's do a shoutout
Troy cam Maura
hey yo bro love your videos can i have a
shout out sure thing Troy lookbook
reporting
ok I'm looking at a photo of you Troy
you look like someone who likes to touch
himself in the mirror or occasionally
record yourself while touching yourself
you know what I used to do Troy here's a
little tip you open up a photo booth on
your Mac and it's better than watching
yourself in America's you can record
yourself touching yourself and then you
can play it back injured after that do
you guys know when you'd ask for a
shout-out you're always gonna get this
oh no no no I'm not asking you I'm
asking them do you know that when you
ask for a shout-out you get this touch
yourself Troy god damn it